This is Maya Fischler. I'm in the home of Jean Starker-Raw and today is November
13th, 2007. Today, Jean and I are going to be talking about some of the community
activities that she's been involved with and I'd like to ask her some questions as
well on a more philosophical side of things asking her to reflect a little bit
about her life and some of the things that she's accomplished.
Okay, so when we left off last time, you had just told me about
Kermit's passing. At that time, your children were grown. Almost everybody was out of
the house and in college and that's it. Except for Kim. Kim was still here.
And she was in the sorority house. She was the same. And then when her dad died,
by then she moved home to be with me. And she was engaged and to be married in
June of that year, he died in February. So she said she'd come home and stay with me.
So I got to know my future son-in-law quite well during that period.
But it was a very tough time to be enthusiastic about a wedding.
And you know, I knew Kermit wasn't going to be with us.
Anyway, that was where that stood, I guess.
Did you have other friends and that sort of thing at that era who were really
comfort to you sort of took you through that difficult?
No, not really. Well, I shouldn't say that. There were a couple of
couples that really stood by me. But it's amazing in that era.
And I think it's true today. When you are no longer a couple,
it's a different story. Different socials.
Yes. And I had one lady tell me very bluntly. She said,
well, I won't be inviting you to dinners anymore. It makes an uneven number.
Interesting. Yeah. And so, you know, people see things differently.
But, um, I'm Izzy Hall of CH2M Hall. She was a,
she and Jim were wonderful support. And I've always,
and now I'm kind of supporting them because Jim has a disease
that he will not get well from. And so, I try to take her out to
lunch and do things with her now. So, you know, it all comes full circle.
Yes, it does. Yeah, that's an interesting statement.
Because I think that has probably changed in this generation.
I don't think there is that same sense that you only socialize with couples.
There's a lot more relationships among women. Yes, that's right.
When there was at that time. And you've probably built those kind of
issues. Yes. And you know, the thing of it is that,
I think that people don't realize when you're in your 50s,
what it's going to be like when you're alone in your 80s.
And people are much more aware of that, I think,
now when they used to be. People were more self-centered, I think.
And then the other thing that I think about my life is that,
Herman and I did everything together. We weren't big on going
places with other couples. We went with our family.
We went fishing. He went hunting with the boys.
And I did my little things with the hospital and that sort of thing.
But basically, we did our social things just together.
Yes. So you had a really special bond and that's hard to recreate.
That's right.
So what kind of things did you do in that time to kind of move
you through the morning stage? Well, I did the wedding.
And that was a full-time job. I can imagine.
And of course, when a person dies, there's so much to take care of.
And as I've mentioned before, I had very little money that was coming in routinely.
I had to figure out how I was going to support myself.
And whether I had to go back to work or what I was going to do.
Because we had a lot of assets, but we didn't have any cash flow.
And so I hired a man to manage the forest lands that were left over from the mill.
And as I've said before, I trusted him implicitly.
But I really didn't feel like I had a handle on it because I didn't know anything about Timberland and managing it.
And so he did a lot of work on...
I don't know what they call that.
He drew pictures of the forest and then where we should log
and what we should do with different sections of it.
And I wish I could put that better. But anyway, that went on for a couple of years.
And when I needed some money, I'd say, you know, got him log.
But then I decided that after I got my wits about me and got kind of settled down, I thought, well, you know, I know a lot about real estate and how that works.
So I think I'll do a 1031 just like my father did.
And so I sold off the Timbermanager surveyed the Timberland that I wanted to sell first
and to see how much I could get from that.
I found a building that I could buy.
And so we exchanged those two and that worked out so well that I did it four more times.
Because that gave you at least a regular source of rent.
That's right because I had the money coming in from the rents from the real estate.
And then I knew how much I had to spend.
So anyway, that worked out very well.
And it's still to this day I own those properties.
You said the BIMART property was one of those two?
Well, the BIMART was a little different because I had inherited that from my mother's estate.
So that was a little bit different.
But it also had a 30 year lease on it which was just peanuts.
You know, because it was so such an old lease.
Why my father did that? I do not know. But anyway, there wasn't much income from that.
I see. Not like it is today.
Yeah. Is that still your property today?
I own that corner there.
Ninth and circle.
And it's been very...
Now that I have a decent lease,
why it gives me some income.
That's good.
So you got involved in your real estate business.
And was at the time that you sort of started getting involved in community activities.
Yes.
And I had always been interested in the hospital because my dad had always...
He was one of the movers and chakers when the hospital was in bankruptcy down here on the Harrison Street.
And he and a group of other men pulled that hospital out of the...
Got it going again.
And then my husband was interested in the hospital and served on the board of the hospital when they moved from Harrison out to the hill.
And so I was always involved in the auxiliary.
And my mother and Mrs. Ed Woodcock were the two ladies who started the held a tea
and asked women to come.
And that's how the auxiliary started the present hospital.
That's interesting.
So that we were always involved as a family more or less in the hospital.
And of course I'm a wind kermit guy.
They made me an honorary trustee of the trustee board.
And so I've been very active in that and helped raise money for the various projects that they've had like the pastega house.
I was co-chair with the heart center with Mario Pastega.
And then I also supported him when he wanted to do his house.
They call it the house.
And so he and I worked together real closely on that.
Fundraising for the most part.
Yes.
And were you also involved in a cancer center there at the hospital?
And the hallway out in that building is named for kermit.
Was that his project as well?
No, really.
I think that was pretty much my project.
But it was one of the first fundraising projects that I had.
Because I knew a lot of people in town.
And I kind of knew who to ask.
Yeah, that's what's important.
You have a long list of things that you've been involved with here.
And I could ask you about each one of them.
But you could also just tell me to direct me a little bit.
Which ones you feel are your major points of pride?
Well, of course the park is very much.
And that was an interesting how that came about.
I yielded or built this house.
And when we were through building it, he came to me and asked me if I would loan him some money to
he owned the corner where the park is.
And he had plans drawn up and he was going to build a big high rise.
Something rather there of office buildings.
And I said, no, I said, I don't think that's what ought to be on that corner.
And I said, the chamber is next door.
You're going to hide the chamber of commerce building.
And as people come over the bridge, they will not see where the chamber is.
And I said, I don't think that ought to be built on that corner.
Well, he picked up on that.
And within, I think it was just two or three weeks.
There was a period of time.
There was a consensus between the university, the city, and the chamber.
And they all pitched in and bought that property from Ike.
And then they came to me and asked if I would landscape it.
And so that's how Kermit's name is on that part.
I see.
So that all worked out just fine.
Everybody was happy.
And I still look after it.
And I get after them when they don't keep the park up.
Because I have also donated funds to the N County Foundation for the purpose of keeping that park up.
They're supposed to use it for the, you know, to put in some perennials and that sort of thing.
And now I'm after the chamber because their trees have grown up so much that you can't see their building.
And I think they ought to take those trees down.
And so that when people come over the bridge, they can see where the chamber is.
That's true.
Yeah.
So anyway, I'm working on that.
That's good.
I've never stopped that kind of thing.
Keep them spiffed up there.
Now let's see.
The other thing I think is that I belong to the homeic.
And that was started.
My interest in that was a long, long, long ago.
Maria Saker was the lady in charge of the homeic part of the State Extension Service.
And she and I had known each other because, of course, I'd grown up in Kervalis and they lived not far from us.
Well, when I was teaching school up in McKenzie by, she called me one day.
Was that in Wade's thing?
Well, taking the job within classup.
No.
This is different day.
So I was up the McKenzie teaching in that summer.
Before the summer was out, she called me one to know if I wanted to job.
In Lane County, doing work with people who wanted to process their produce,
either canning or freezing or whatever.
And I said, oh, I'd love a job for the summer.
So she said, well, fine.
And so then about halfway through the summer, why she called me and she said we had an opening in an Astoria for a war food assistant.
And this is during the war.
Yes, you did tell me about that.
Oh, okay.
Well, then I won't repeat that.
And so that's how I got into the extension service because then the war food assistant was then the class of county liked what we did up there with the women.
And so they asked, you see extension services is funded by federal state and county funds.
And so the county was going to go ahead and do their part to fund the extension service.
And that guy was still going.
But I started that whole program up there.
So that was part of the state home economic system.
Yes.
And then you became a trustee on that.
What they call a home demonstration age.
And otherwise known as a home demon.
That's kind of a positive and a negative.
That word I guess you could see.
And then eventually you became the chair of the College of Home Economic Development Council.
Yes.
That was the step that you took.
Yes, that was when a Kinsey Green was dean and I was chairman of the advisory committee for probably six or seven years.
And then when Tammy Bray became the dean, why she asked me to continue.
However, we don't have a chairman I don't think as such.
We just have advisory committee.
I see.
And what are the some of the projects that you did through that group that you wrote?
We raised money too for the college.
And we talk about where the college is going, what needs to be done, what needs to be processed in the way of whatever we think that people ought to be thinking about.
When Tammy Bray took over that dean ship, it was combined with the College of Physical Education, I think it was.
And then they called it Health and Human Science.
And so she came to me and wanted to know about the history of home economic side of that.
And then she had the other group.
And we formed them together.
So now we do both.
I see.
And is that the group that started the Bates Family Study Center?
Yes.
And I was on that committee to help with that.
What is the purpose of that study center?
It's mostly studies of either children development, which is they have a nursery school there.
And also gerontology.
There is a gerontology department also.
But it's expanded a lot since we started.
I think there's lots of research goes on in there.
I don't know.
I think the bone density project is probably in the basement of the women's building.
I don't think it's over at the Bates Center.
But it's all intertwined, all of that research.
So the Bates Center is an actual building?
Yes.
And I was on the committee that helped fund that.
We raised quite a bit of money for that.
Among them was the lady who was the original Betty Crocker.
And she was a graduate of Oregon State.
I didn't realize that.
Yes.
And so I'm trying to forget her name.
Anyway, she came out here and worked with us to get it going.
And took a big interest in it.
And of course left us the big sum of money that the major donor of that building.
Because it's named after her.
Well, she didn't like much staying downtown at the hotel.
So she used to come and stay with me.
So I enjoyed being with her because we had an awfully good time when she stayed with me.
And then I would take her around where she wanted to go.
That time I drove a lot better than I drive now.
And so I provided transportation for her.
What was fun?
So was she older than you?
Oh, yes.
She's been gone many years now.
She began to go downhill during the time that she gave the money to the family study center.
And then the last time she came out, she really wasn't herself.
She came with a gentleman who was her...
I don't know what you call him, but a consultant for their money.
He took over caring for her too.
But she stayed with me and he stayed downtown.
That's fun.
So I asked Mercedez Bates.
Mercedez Bates?
I have heard that name.
It's an awful way to forget people like that.
I just did it earlier today.
So you were also involved in the 4-H Foundation at the state level?
Yes.
Because I had...
I think we talked about that.
When I was growing up, I had the daughter of the head of the state.
Harry Seymour was head of the state.
And I had her...
His daughter for my 4-H teacher, our leader, I guess you'd say.
So I was always active in 4-H.
And when my children came along, they were active in 4-H.
Both of the girls had...
They were state winners in the dress competition.
They took...
I taught them some, but they had a great leader.
Mrs. Wells was her name.
They lived out on the corner of Walnut in...
Where's the stop sign at Walnut before you go up the hill?
There's a stop light there at 27th and then at 29th.
Well, I think it's the one at 29th.
Because that's the one where you go out 29th and go up and around the hill and then down.
Well, she lived at that corner.
And she was a great leader.
She knew a lot about sewing.
And I thought it was better for the girls to get it from somebody else than me.
So they went out there and sewed a lot for her.
And then my dad was one of the movers and shakers along with...
The guy that was head of the state 4-H, his name.
We'll have to look that up.
I don't remember what...
I Burton sticks in my...
Burton Hutton.
Maybe that was the name.
I can check on that too.
Yeah, put a question right there because I don't know for sure.
Anyway, Burton Hutton...
Well, just say that's who it is.
Came to my dad and he wanted to buy this property over in Salem.
That was for sale and it was Timberman.
And so my dad went over there and the idea was to build a camp for 4-H's.
Well, it was a pretty big project.
And my dad was very involved in that.
And so then when it came along, I was a treasure, I think.
I don't know.
I was some officer in the 4-H program that was established to run that camp.
At the state level?
Yes.
Eventually, we had to sell off half of the Timberland, which just killed me
because it should have been self-sustaining.
People don't realize that Timber is a renewable resource.
And you just harvested every 40 years instead of every year, like a lot of crops.
And so we could have, if we'd been able to save that land,
we could have had it rotating so that we could have always had some income,
but didn't work out.
But they did save half of it.
And now we've got a really wonderful fundraiser, Randy, his name,
but he's last name is.
He's great, and he is running the camp, and they're just,
and they're getting, what do you call it?
I want to say they're applying for fundraising for grants.
For grants?
Yes, yes.
And so now they're just doing really well, and they're able to keep it up,
and it looks great.
And so I was involved in that as being on the 4-H board.
And so I became very interested in that because I wanted to see it go.
Sure.
And my dad provided money for the swimming pool of that camp,
and then Kermit and I gave some money for the upkeep of it.
It seems like, in general, you had a few swimming-related gifts that you gave.
Was there a special reason that you were interested in it?
We were always thought that swimming was very important for Oregonians
because we have so much water.
And when we would see people drown because they couldn't swim, we learned to swim.
We thought that was just terrible.
And so we've always supported water-related activities.
And I still do that because I support, through the Benton County Foundation,
I support, for instance, lifts for people to get in and out of pools so they can swim.
And then I think we already talked about the girls going to camp.
To a spring win.
Yes, and they didn't want to go back because it wasn't a swim.
So Kermit and I talked it over and we'd made some money in the stock market
and so we decided we'd give stock to them and so they built their swimming pool.
But we wouldn't let anybody know that we'd done that because we didn't want the kids to go to camp
and everybody saying, hey, to the swimming pool, you know.
So it's never been named or anything.
I think that's interesting.
We didn't want the kids to know.
So did your family always have a swimming pool?
Yes, we always did.
And your kids were growing up?
At least when Kermit and I, we always had a swimming pool.
Of course, my dad didn't because he supported the 4-H one, but he didn't support family.
But we did have a pond out in the woods that we could use in the summertime.
But Kermit was, I think, did I tell you about him building that swimming pool?
No.
Well, when we build our house over on Jackson Street, we didn't have a swimming pool.
And so he came home one day and he said, what would you think if we build a swimming pool
across the property across the way that we owned?
And he said, I could bring in 12 by 12 timbers and put them together in the corners.
And then we could put your paper down for the paint job and then put plastic around it.
And it would be 4 feet deep.
And I said, well, I think that would be great because the kids were little and they could have a lot of fun.
And it was just like a big puddle pool.
So we did that.
And I think that lasted for probably five or six years every year.
We would tear it down and re-put your paper in plastic.
And it would last the summer.
And then we decided we'd build a swimming pool.
So we did that.
But it wasn't covered.
And so that wasn't very satisfactory in Oregon.
So when he closed the mail, he came to me and he said,
I've got to take the metal off the roof of some of the machinery that are in the mail.
And he said, if we cleaned it up and cut off the end where the logs have hit it,
he said, I could bring that metal in and we could have a building over the pool.
And I said, no thank you.
I don't want a metal building in my yard.
And he said, well, now just wait a minute.
I'll tell you about how we're going to do this.
It's better than you think.
So anyway, the back part of it was all metal.
And then we put boards that was a very nice awning over the front of it.
That was all wood.
And then we had sliding glass doors.
And from the street you couldn't tell what it was.
It's still there.
So it covered over the whole pool.
And we built a sink and a bathroom out there.
And a boys and girls dressed in rooms.
And it was really a nice little.
As we entertained all the kids in on the campfire, girls, the boys,
girls, the 4-H kids who ever came around.
This was wonderful because the kids were at our house.
And we knew what they were doing.
Absolutely.
And so it was just a wonderful pool for the kids all the time they were growing up.
That's great.
And so that's still in use over there?
Oh yeah, so.
That's good.
That sort of leads me to my, I wanted to ask a little bit about Kermit's community involvement.
Because I know it sounded like he was also involved in the Scouts to a certain extent.
Yes, he was with the Scouts in Eugene.
I don't know what level of Scouting that was, but whatever it was, he used to go out of Eugene to meetings with Boy Scouts.
And it was very active.
And he did a lot of fundraising for the Boy Scouts.
He always said that he didn't like to ask people for money.
But because of his relationship with the Mill, there were lots of times when he had partial lots of something that he couldn't really sell.
But they were very usable.
So he would donate those.
He liked in-kind giving.
And he got canoes for the Boy Scouts.
And he would ask various people who manufactured things if he thought the Scouts could use it.
And that worked very well.
In fact, I still do that a lot with my fundraising.
We try to get in-kind gifts.
Interesting.
Because people don't mind giving things that they've manufactured.
And those canoes were perfectly good.
But maybe they had a chip out of the paint or something they couldn't sell on.
But they were perfectly usable.
Interesting.
Yeah, that's a great service to provide.
Yes.
And giving was his thing.
Interesting.
But he was also involved with the Rotary and other groups around town.
Yes, he was a Rotarian.
And after he died, I made him a fellow in the Rotary Club.
And he was really fond of the Rotary Group.
Were there some things that he was particularly involved with that things that were close to him?
I don't remember that he was in particularly involved with Rotary.
But he may have been more than I realized I don't know.
But he was involved in the Church.
He was a Trustee of the Church.
He did that.
He wasn't a joiner, really.
He didn't like to join very much, really.
So he did his work on the outskirts as well?
Yes.
That works that well.
Another thing I have on the list of your credits is the EE Wilson Foundation.
What's been your involvement there?
Well, I was on that for a number of years.
And Fred Zewallon was head of that and managed it from the very beginning when EE Wilson died.
And I knew EE Wilson.
And so I guess they thought that I would be interested in managing what he had given to the college.
And really wasn't to the college.
It was just...
I think it was kind of just given, but he had to have a board managing it.
And Pete Smith lived next door to us over on Jackson.
And he was on the board.
And so then he got me involved and I was on that for a number of years.
Is that managing the lands?
No, the money that was in the bank that was accumulating interest and so forth.
And the duty of the board was to have kids apply for money from that.
And then we had to read their applications and decide who was going to get what.
So scholarships for OSU?
Yes, I see.
Well, it could be...
As I remember it, it could be any...
I've kind of forgotten.
I think it's any Oregon school that I can't remember.
That scholarship is still available.
Yes, it is.
It seems to me like it has to be Benton County Youth.
It could be.
I think it is.
Boy, that was a long time ago when I served on that.
I see you haven't done that for a while.
No.
So most recently the things that you're still involved in...
Are you still involved in the 4-H or the economics at all?
Well, I'm still...
I serve on the advisory committee for the HOMEC...
HOMEC helped the human side.
And the library.
And the hospital is an honorary trustee.
And the museum of Benton County Museum.
That's...
There's a lot of responsibilities.
Well, I've quit the...
Just recently, I've quit the museum.
And I've quit the library.
So I'm down to the hospital and the health and human side.
And you've quit them just to give yourself a little more free time?
Yes.
It's just too much.
It is.
But it's an incredible gift to the community.
Do you think that that...
As you were talking about how...
You know, you had a good year in the stocks or whatever
and then you'd give to this cause or another.
Do you think that's still going on at that same level in this day and age?
That's the same sense of philanthropy that people of your era had?
No, I don't think so.
I think everything now is based on what I can do to get rid of the money for tax purposes.
I really think that people give to get their tax off.
And of course, I've always believed that I would like to give money to something where I know it's going.
Then to taxes.
So I try to give as much as I can and not have to pay tax on it.
But it seems like your choice of beneficiaries has a lot to do with your personal interests.
Yes.
Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
You're personally involved not only in terms of giving money but also in giving an expertise and advice.
Yeah.
Because I want to know what they're doing with the money that I've come up with.
I think that makes you different than some other donors too in some ways.
Oh, probably.
A lot of people give money and then they're done.
They don't pay attention.
But I really like to know what they're doing with it.
Absolutely.
The one big organization that you've given to is OSU.
We haven't talked about that at all.
But I'd love to hear more about your involvement there and all the things that you've contributed.
I know a lot of it has been real estate fundraising for various real estate ventures.
Is that true?
Well, I think that when you know a lot of all of this stuff that goes on is who you know.
And I'm really proud of the fact that there were three ships available or fishing vessels I should say available in Newport.
But I had become very friendly with Bruce Maid and his wife Mary-Due and his mother.
Because they wanted me to go on a trip and his mother needed a roommate.
So I said, well, I would go in room with her.
Well, we just got along fine and we just became really good friends over Newport.
So anyway, the more I heard about what Bruce Maid was doing,
I was very impressed with what he does and his science that he's promoted with whales.
So anyway, there were some when the fishing industry over there,
and we kind of went kapoot by there were three men who wanted to donate their boats to a issue for research.
Well, the trustees, who were the people who say yes or no, there's a little board that does that?
They didn't know what did they do about Bruce Maid and never heard of him and didn't know anything about him.
Well, I had followed him because he's on BBC and he's on history channels and all of those things.
And he was doing great things about tagging whales so that they knew where they were going and what they were doing.
And so John Irving was one of the men who was trying to get the board, the boys you board,
to accept these ships because he thought it was a great thing for them to be able to re-retrofit them and get them fixed for research.
Well, so far they've only done one but they're available but anyway backing up, he called me one day and he said,
would I be willing to speak to the trustees about Bruce Maid?
And I said, oh, I'd love to because I really think he does a good job.
So anyway, I told him, I said, how many of you know Bruce, the name Bruce Maid?
They looked at each other.
So I proceeded to tell him who he was and what he'd done and what wonderful research he was doing.
So then they were all skittery shit about the insurance on these boats.
But they finally worked it out with, I don't know who, but anyway, they accepted the three boats and I'm really proud of the fact that I kind of encouraged him to do.
Absolutely, yeah.
But you know sometimes it's just who you know.
That's right, and having that personal touch, you know, and willing to be there and say, yeah, I know of this man and I can speak for him.
That's right.
And I can tell him a little bit about what he does.
His mother, I don't know whether you want to put anything about this in but I think she's such a tear woman.
She's just a little short thing. She's probably not five feet tall.
She studied under Frank Lloyd Wright and has a registered architect.
She studied a library of science and as a degree in whatever library is and she's this one smart lady.
She's just a there and has a wonderful sense of humor.
Just enjoyed her knowing.
Oh, that's great.
Unfortunately, now she's in a rest home in Newport.
Doesn't have her mind very clear right now, but she's getting older with some of the rest of us.
So you've done some work as a lot of work through the foundation as well through the OSU foundation.
Well, I'm on the OSU foundation.
I wouldn't say I do much work, but I go and I see.
So that's more of being a member of the board and not necessarily any of the things that you're most proud of, huh?
No, in fact, I'm not very proud of what they're doing right now.
You won't put that in.
We won't, okay.
All right.
You say so.
Are there things that OSU that you look at and think I'm so pleased beyond the both that you got for Bruce's project, but are there other things there that you look at and think I'm so glad to have been a contributor to this?
Well, the library, of course.
I think her library is just one of the nicest ones in the Northwest.
It's amazing.
And I'm very supportive of Carol Butcher.
I think she does some very innovative things.
The most recent one that she's done is having that babysitting area that she has and the students can come and bring.
If they're studying in the library, they have to stay in the library.
But if they're studying, they can bring their children and let them off at this little care center.
And they're given a thing like you get in restaurants, you know, when you're in Beeper.
So kind of a beeper?
Yes, a beeper.
And so if they need them, they can beep the mother and her father was a case maybe these days.
And I think that's quite innovative.
I didn't know about that.
Yes, it's quite a nice project.
They have a little, they've done some interesting things with the plumbing because of course they needed to toilet.
And it's a little, really nice little porta potting.
And so they didn't put in actual plumbing.
But I think it's very well designed.
And they have students in there that are learning childcare.
I think it's just a great project.
I'll have to check that out.
Terrific.
Well, and you're such a beaver fan.
Oh yes, I'm a beaver.
That should definitely be in there too, I think.
Well, you know, since I've lived in Kerala's all my life, there's no, you know, I had three out of my four children go through Oregon State.
And my husband was a graduate of Oregon State.
And I've worked for the college through the extension service.
And you know, we've just been involved in the university all our lives.
And of course my father worked at the university.
And you know, you're just kind of all, that's where your life has been.
That's right, yeah.
But I love the fact that you still go to the football games.
Oh yes, oh yes.
Oh, that football game Saturday night was something.
It's like that they're doing so well this year.
He was just so proud.
But all the officiating was aww.
Was it?
It was just terrible.
And even Mike Riley, who calls the games for the radio, he said it was the worst officiating he'd ever seen in his life.
That's a statement.
Yes.
And the paper, I think Riley asked him to downplay it probably.
But he's a very low key guy.
But boy was he upset with the officiating.
He called one of the plays, you know, and asked him to read through it.
Really?
And they did change it.
So yeah, it was a feisty game.
Good, good.
And you still go to those with your family?
Yes, in fact, I did go with my daughter and son-in-law this time.
Sometimes I use tickets for guests.
I like to entertain that way.
Because I have the tickets.
I might as well use them for something.
That's right.
Your support of the sports angle of the OSU in general, it seems like that's a particular emphasis for you.
Yes, and I really like basketball better.
I go to all the basketball games.
You're not doing very well on basketball this year.
But of course, when Ralph Miller was there, why it was just wonderful.
Well, that's good.
So are there any other projects that you think you'd like to talk about in here, things that you're particularly proud of?
Well, I guess I'm particularly proud of my kids.
Well, I would love to get back to that, because we sort of talked about their younger life when we were here a couple of weeks ago.
But I'd like to hear about them today and what you're most proud of each of them.
Well, Ken's the oldest.
And he lives in Southern California.
And he has two sons.
And the grandchildren are doing most welcome.
Derrick is his oldest son.
And he's married to Mindy.
And they have three children now, and they're...
She's a...
What do they call that school?
Montessori school teacher and has a school in their home.
And Derrick is very handy, and he's made a dollhouse, and he's made slides, and he's made...
They have half their yard for the school and half the yard for their own private.
And the kids know when they come that they don't go on that side of the yard.
But they just do a whale of a job.
They're growing up to be such fine young people.
And I'm very proud of them.
And my Ken lives in...
I don't know what Ken does, and he's on the California Water Board.
He does something about that.
He's also done something with hazardous waste.
He's been on committees about that.
Is he an engineer?
No, he really isn't.
He was a business major.
He started out as being a forest major.
But every time he went to class, he had a field trip.
He had poison oak, and so he had to give that up.
And so he was a business major.
And then he got his MBA and...
Oh my god, I did it.
Something.
But he's dabbled in a lot of things.
And he lives in on ten acres in an avocado grove
and raises those great big avocados.
Oh yes, those are great.
So good.
And his wife is a psychologist.
And the children all call her the shrink.
That's great.
And their second son?
And the second one was in the military.
What's his name?
Danny.
Danny, huh?
And he was in the military for about ten years, I think,
and married a really nice girl.
And they have two children.
And he's out of the military now,
and taking auto mechanics.
Well, I guess you'd say mechanics,
because I think it's a combination of auto and airplane mechanics.
He likes to work with his hands.
So he does that.
Then Craig's the next boy.
And he lives in Bend.
And he does, well, I don't know what Craig does.
He runs some sort of a business called Bad Checks.
And he takes checks that are bouncing
and does something with him.
And I've never been able to figure out what he does.
But anyway, he does that.
And then he's a hunter and a fisherman.
It seems to earn enough money to play quite a bit.
And he also has some friends who are quite wealthy.
And he goes with them a lot because Craig's a fun guy.
So you have children as well?
Yes, he has two.
And what is going to school here at LVCC?
And is going to be...
She's studying to be a...
Well, I don't know what she's studying to be.
Anyway, she's going to school.
What's her name?
Tracy.
And then Mackenzie goes to Skad,
which is Savannah College of Art and Design in Savannah, Georgia.
And she's studying jewelry.
And she apparently is very good,
because she just designed some piece
that the teacher is taking to Hong Kong to show
some group that are over there.
I guess it's quite a thing in her butt.
She has been thinking that she would like to buy a Savannah house,
you know, an antique house of some sort.
And have a store below, a jewelry store below, and live above.
So she's got her life all figured out.
Then there's Kathy, who lives in Portland, K-A-T-H-Y.
And she's married to Mead Clifford,
which is kind of interesting,
because you know, we have a man over here who was Clifford Mead.
I do.
And the...
A Linus Pauling Institute.
Right, to the University.
So anyway, you've got to be careful with which way you get that.
And he was a man who...
Man, he called it...
What did he call that business?
Anyway, it was storing hospital records.
And he built that up to a very big business.
And then all of a sudden Iron Mountain came in
and they were an international company.
And they bought him out.
So he does some other things now.
Did they have children?
Yes, they have three.
And the oldest one is Brent.
And he goes to school at...
Oh, I can't tell you.
It's one of the California schools.
It's San Diego.
It's the Catholic school that's in San Diego up on the hill.
Very prestigious school.
But I never know whether it's a university...
No, I don't think it's got university in it because it's a private...
It's a Catholic school.
They are a Catholic.
But he wanted to go to someplace where he could wear flip-flops and shorts.
He found it.
So he's going to graduate this year.
And he thinks he's going to go to law school.
That's great.
And then Colin is the high school senior.
I don't know what I'm going to do about graduation this year.
We've got all these kids graduating.
And Mackenzie will graduate from SCAD.
Brent's going to graduate from California.
Colin's going to graduate from Lincoln High School.
And you know, how do I want to be able to go always?
You'll have to map it out with a calendar.
That's Colin and he goes to Lincoln High School.
Was his interest, do you know?
Well, the poor kid, he's had health problems.
He wants to be an athlete but he just had his tonsils out.
And it was a real brutal operation.
He was in the hospital for two or three days with tonsils.
Yeah, he don't hear about that much anymore.
They say that when you're older and you have your tonsils out, it's real rough.
And it was.
He just had a few days there of being miserable.
So I don't know what Colin will be interested in.
He's looking at schools now.
And then there's little Brent who is interested in nothing but look-cross.
And you said Brent was the oldest?
Yes.
Then Colin and then Brent.
Brent?
I see, I got two Brent somehow.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Brent is what I meant.
Brent is the oldest.
Okay.
And then Brent.
Alright.
And Brent's lacrosse.
Oh, that's his.
Lea sleeps, eats, everything.
And lacrosse.
And I guess he's a pretty good little player because he was chosen as one of two
in the Portland district to represent the teams that play.
He's played in Philadelphia and this is middle school.
Oh, he's still in middle school.
That's amazing.
And he played in Philadelphia and he played in Seattle and he played in Southern California.
Understand that.
I think that's too much for middle school kids.
Oh, yeah, but that's what they do these days.
Oh, yes.
It sure is.
And I guess he's pretty darn good.
So that's his passion.
And then there's Kim.
She's the baby.
And she's married to Walt.
And she and Walt are now doing the courtyard.
Do you know what you're talking about the courtyard?
And that's Revolence.
Revolence.
Like they call it.
And they've been working really hard to get the students to get it fixed up so that students
can live there.
It was in terrible shape.
And they've got 14 students living there.
And they're the nicest young people.
They have to be kind of religiously oriented, not any particular denomination.
And they're all enthusiastic about where they live.
And they're spreading the word.
And Kim said, by next year they'll have a waiting list.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
So are they living here in town while they were here?
Yes, they live out at the end of 29th Street.
Oh, great.
Clear up in the hills.
Otherwise, did she live in Portland before?
Yes, so.
Has she lived completely down here?
And yes, Walt's been an interesting husband.
He was an FFA boy.
And when he finished college, he had six screenhouses and ran a nursery.
And he went to Carter culture in college.
But he's gone through all the work for a rubber company and he worked for it.
He's always landed on his feet with a very good job.
But now they're deciding that they'll do this.
Who knows what they'll do?
And she was a teacher?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, she was trained as a teacher.
She's not doing that anymore?
No, no.
She's working with Walt.
I'm with Walt's.
That's great.
She was substituting when they lived in Portland.
Uh-huh.
Great.
And they have twin daughters, Jennifer and Kristen.
And Kristen is, she graduated from Seattle Pacific.
And in business and has a job in Portland with a computer company that she hates her job.
That's good money.
And Jennifer has graduated in Home Economics, where we'll help in human science.
And she has a job in Portland that she just loves, but doesn't make much money.
It's so often that's a trade-off.
But it's fun that she's continuing on in the Home Economics field.
Well, no, she manages an office for some brokers.
Oh, she does.
She has her degree, but she doesn't use it, huh?
No.
Oh.
Well, still, she has the same interest that you did in Home Economics.
It's nice that you share that.
Well, yes, she did.
And she worked a lot in kid spirit when she was here.
And school.
She worked at kid spirit almost all the time.
She was here.
So it's wonderful that you can even name all these grandchildren and talk about each of them individually.
Did you spend a lot of time with them when they were growing up?
Well, more so with Kim's children than the rest of them because they were in Portland.
And well, I spend time with Kathy's children when they were younger,
but I don't drive to Portland anymore, so I don't see them nearly as often as I used to.
But I know they stay in touch just from the fact that last time I was here,
one of somebody called me, one of your California grandchildren, called in.
Oh, yeah, they all called.
We think cell phones are just great.
That's good.
Yeah.
What were some of the things that you did with them when you could get to spend time with them?
Well, we shopped a lot.
And they love to shop with grandma because you know who buys some stuff.
Yeah, my kids are the same.
But we did a lot of things together.
And we had a lot of picnics together.
Did you ever share your cooking and sewing in those kind of skills with them?
Well, not much.
Maybe making sugar cookies.
They all like my sugar cookies.
And this holiday I'm taking the rolls and the sugar cookies for my part of the Thanksgiving dinner.
Oh, that's good.
And last night Craig said, I said something about boy who had taken me a long time to make rolls.
I said, I just got as fast as I used to be.
And he said, well, don't worry about the rolls.
Just bring the sugar cookies.
It's kind of priorities.
That's a good thing.
That's kind of the thing that I'm noted for.
That's good.
Did you have that experience of just finding out how much fun it was to be a grandparent
with enjoying your time with them and not having quite as much of the work as you do when you're a parent?
Well, I loved when Kim had her twins because she lived in Lebanon at that time.
And Walt was still doing the nursery.
And so when she and Walt were married, she had another year in school.
She was married when she was a junior and Walt was a senior.
But her daddy had said, I don't mind you getting married, but he said, you're going to finish school.
Well, of course, what happened was that she got pregnant.
And then they found out they were having twins.
And of course, in the meantime, he died.
And so anyway, I said, you know you promised your daddy that if you got married and she said, I know.
So anyway, I said, my advice to you is to get busy and she only had her doom teaching to do.
And I said, you need to do that before your kids get mobile.
I said, it's a lot easier to take care of them when they're in the, in the, in not wandering around.
And Walt was home during the day because he was running the nursery.
So if there was an emergency, he was there. So that worked out well.
So anyway, Kim was able to get a student teaching situation in Lebanon.
So she wasn't far away.
And so she finished up and got her degree while she was doing that.
But I was over there a lot taking care of the youngsters.
And they'd have full time help.
But it was, you know, I like to go over there and help feed the kids.
I can imagine.
She was a great mother.
She twins didn't bother Kim at all.
She, I can still see her sitting on the dab important.
One baby would be laying over there and she'd be feeding this one.
And that one would be yelling.
And she'd pat him on the back and say, now it's your turn next.
Oh, so good for her.
She was a wonderful mother.
Great.
Good.
So with that, last time when I was here and you got that phone call,
you were going to be sending down one of your boys' jackets to one of your great-grandson.
Yes, yes, and I did that.
And he's absolutely ecstatic.
That is so sweet.
Yeah, this one was born.
Actually, this one was a red flannel Boy Scout jacket.
I don't know if you know, but that's quite a deal when they get that.
And then they put all their patches on it.
And so this one was all covered in patches.
And so I said to Ken, my son, I said, what do you think I ought to do with these patches?
And he said, well, I take them off because he needs to earn his own patches.
So anyway, I've got them all in a little ziplock bag.
And I'm taking them over to Craig who earned the patches.
And then sent the coat to the cleaners.
And it's been sent down to what's his name?
One of those guys down there.
You get the name of the great-grandchildren, I guess.
Derek or Danny's kids, huh?
Yeah, well, it's Derek's kids.
Well, anyway, whoever's getting it.
And he said, so Ken called me and he said, boy, is he one happy boy?
He said, he's just crazy about it.
And you know, it looked brand-new when it got back from the cleaners.
It was just great.
That's fun.
I mean, it fluffed up all of the sewing that had been on it.
It worked out just really well.
That's good.
Good.
Well, are there other things that you saved from when you were a little girl
that you have been able to pass on to your grandchildren that they've enjoyed?
Well, I don't really think of anything off-hand.
Oh, no, I don't.
The only thing that I have saved really of Kathy's is that she made a dress
with beautiful satin stitch.
I could show that to you.
I think it's a real special little dress.
And it's been hanging back there for 20 hairs just because I enjoy looking at it.
Uh-huh.
Do you want to see it?
I'd love to.
Well, let's wait till we're done.
We'll go out.
We'll go down there.
Unless you need to get up in the stretcher.
No, no.
I'm just stretching my legs out.
Yeah, we're doing here for time.
Let's see.
Two thirds.
Should we plan to stop at three again?
It's two.
It's 20 minutes to three now.
I have to be fine.
Okay.
All right.
Let's see.
And then we're just about through four.
We are.
I think this will be our last formal get together.
Uh-huh.
I want to keep open the possibility of giving you a call while I'm putting this together.
Yes, absolutely.
You might understand me.
So I had some sort of general questions that are more or less reflections on life.
And you could tell me if you're comfortable answering these kinds of things.
But I like to have a little bit of people's philosophy in these books too.
Because I feel like what you're leaving with this book is a statement of your legacy.
There's so much about your death legacy out there.
And I think, well, Gene has a legacy of her own that she's leaving here.
Do you have a sense of what you want your legacy to be,
what you think your children and your community should remember about you?
Oh gosh, those are hard things to answer.
I should have given you these questions in advance.
Yeah.
Because I just hope that people remember that I tried to live by the golden rule.
I guess it's my philosophy.
I'd like to have people treat me like I want to be treated and like I want to treat them.
And I've always kind of lived by that, hopefully, by that philosophy that I don't know really what else to say about that.
I want to feel like I'm on this earth that I'm contributing something to society.
And I guess that that's why I like to get out and do things.
Because I don't want to just sit.
Right.
Just stay active.
And we haven't talked about knitting either, have we?
I'd like to hear more.
That's one of my hobbies.
You've shown me.
And you actually told me that you got started on that back when you were in high school.
When you were waiting for your dad to pick you up.
Right.
This piece is coming along nicely, though. Are you getting close to the end of it?
Yes, I'm getting quite close to the end of it.
Just love the colors that you chose for that.
This is for Colin.
Uh-huh.
And I've made a midday.
At the end there.
Oh, did I losing something?
Not quite.
I've made an African for each one of the children.
Most of them, at least the ones that have asked for it.
Uh-huh.
And so he's a big boy and so he wanted something heavy and his mother wanted something that he wouldn't put his toes through.
Good point, uh-huh.
And so that's for that.
But this one is, and you know, we might take a picture of that one time.
Because I'm most proud of this African that I made.
I think it's the one that I did.
Well, I was waiting for him when he was a football player.
And I've been most of this under a street light.
Waiting in your car while he was at practice?
Yes, it's gorgeous.
And I've got a variety of stitches in this one.
So I'm really pleased with this one.
Now, how did you end up with that if you knitted it for him?
Oh, I didn't knit it for him.
I'll just knit it for you.
Wow, he was playing.
Oh, I knit it for myself.
It's just gorgeous.
Well, I've had almost a sampler, isn't it, with all the-
Yes, it is.
It's kind of stitching in it.
But I've knit, I don't know how many of these.
I knit one for Uncle Norm.
That was my husband's brother.
And he had a real hard time.
When he was getting older, they just kind of chopped him in pieces.
He lost his leg and you know, an arm.
Did you have diabetes, sir?
No, I don't know what he had.
It's a long time ago and I forgot what he had.
But anyway, he needed a blanket to keep warm.
He didn't have very good circulation.
So I knit him one and I get-
I don't know how many askins I've made.
I might take a picture of that one too before I leave here.
I'd love to have a picture of that to put in the book as well.
Well, I think I'm real proud of this one.
Yeah, it's really gorgeous.
It's probably the fanciest one that I've got.
And I do needle point.
That's a needle point one that I did.
Which one?
That one.
The pillow?
Beautiful.
I love the colors.
I have a couple at the beach that I've done in shells.
Wow.
That sort of thing.
Oh, I kind of have good eyes for that project.
Yeah.
Tiny little stitches.
I did all of it except the border.
And I got to the point where I just couldn't do those fine stitches.
It was pink on the background too and I couldn't see where I'd been and where I was going.
Yeah, so who finished it up for you?
But Kathy, she does.
She does beautiful needle point.
She has inherited more of my clothing and textiles skills.
Ability skills and anybody else.
Kim doesn't like to do that much.
So you've been a single woman for quite a long time.
I'm sure that has its challenges but are there parts of that that have been good for you that have helped you to grow?
Well, I think Kermit and I never got to travel very much.
We did have that one lovely trip to Japan that I think we talked about and how we happened to go to Japan and so forth.
But when this Uncle Norm died, my sister-in-law and I traveled quite a bit.
We probably went on five or six lovely trips and we traveled in Europe a lot because my husband never wanted to go to Europe.
There was something about the World War II that he just didn't want to go to Europe.
But we did go a lot to other parts of the world.
But anyway, Marie and I traveled quite a bit together.
And I always enjoyed that.
And then when my brother died, Betty, my sister-in-law and I traveled quite a bit together.
So I really enjoyed all of that very much.
So it kind of freed you up to have that kind of experience with other people?
Right, right.
And I had enough income then to support some travel.
So it worked out well.
Yeah.
When you're traveling, you're sort of seeing the world and seeing however other people live.
Are there parts of that whole traveling thing that really appealed to you?
Well, of course Hawaii is my favorite place because it's clean.
They speak English and money is the same.
It's easy, huh?
Yeah, it's easy.
And of course the weather's always good.
And I don't remember who did we talk about Betty and I owning a condominium over there.
No, although I saw that somewhere else and I meant to ask you about that.
So you have a condominium together?
We did.
Well, you don't have it anymore.
No, well, of course she's gone.
She's been gone for several years.
But we were...
She had Alzheimer's.
And when we decided that we wanted to do this condominium together, we said that we were just going to let the family use it.
Well, all of a sudden I began to hear people were thanking me for going to here and stay in my condominium.
Well, I thought that she was being a little bit presumptuous.
But it turned out that she really had not remembered that we had this understanding.
And so anyway, I said that I didn't give her any reason why.
But I just said that I thought that maybe I wasn't going to be interested in having the condominium anymore.
And she said, well, she'd buy me out.
So it was all very amenable and everything.
And then I realized a few years later that she just really wasn't herself.
So it was okay.
And my nephews just couldn't be nicer to me.
They're just wonderful boys.
That's great.
So when you were in Hawaii, did you do that?
You said Kermit was a scuba diver early on.
Were you a scuba diver as well?
Yes.
He taught me how to scuba dive and we always went snorkeling.
And I wasn't comfortable going by myself too much.
And so he would always take my hand and go out together and look and then he'd say,
but Betty and I did a lot of that too because she liked to snorkel.
So when we had our condominium, we would go snorkeling almost every day.
Oh, that sounds wonderful.
How long did you have it together?
About three years.
That was great.
And I think most of the kids had it once or twice.
They all went over once or twice.
They were at the age where they didn't have a lot of extra money for the fare over and then along the staying.
And so they could manage it every once in a while, but not too often.
It sounds like a real treat.
And you had taken them over quite a bit when they were younger.
Yes, we'd always gone over on spring break.
That's how it worked out.
Good.
One thing we didn't talk about, I know that Kermit was involved in the church and you've always been involved with the church as well.
Do you consider yourself a spiritual person?
Well, I think I am.
I think I'm not a...
I don't talk about religion too much.
My daughter and son-in-law, Kim and Walter, are very religious in me.
They talk about it all the time and they pray before heels and that sort of thing.
I'm more of a one who keeps their religion kind of to themselves.
And my husband, I think I've got a lot of his feelings in me because he always said that if he dealt with some businessman who broadcast his religion and had visible things on his desk that portrayed his religion.
It just raised a red flag with him because he said, I know too many men who go to church every Sunday and just pull back by you during the week.
And I think I've inherited a lot of that feeling.
I try to live by the golden rule, as I say.
All right, well, we have just about five more minutes and I think I can limit us to maybe three questions.
The other sort of big picture issue I wanted to ask you about was whether there were any sort of social or political issues that have been important to you as you've come through your life.
Are there any things that have been...
Well, I'm a firm believer that you should...
What is it about the babies?
I think it should be between your husband and your doctor and yourself.
And I'm really myth that people can't see that, that it's none of the government's business.
Yeah, I'm sure I am.
Have you ever been active in any of those kinds of causes or have just a personally held belief?
I'm not a cause person.
That's good.
You've been active in causes sort of...
In the back of your influence, yes, I think.
And I guess the other thing is that in church too, I feel that if you want to be a lesbian, I guess.
The congregational church is big on people being lesbians.
And I had to give up the congregational church even though with my background is in the congregational church.
But it's also in the Presbyterian church.
But I'm a Presbyterian now because I could...
I don't know if you remember this, but probably 10, maybe 15 years ago.
A lady came and was part of the Presbyterian church.
And I think she was the Sunday school teacher that they hired the young people.
And she thought that lesbians were just the best thing that ever happened to anybody.
And she would have...
When she first came, there was a picture of her in the paper almost every week about what she believed in.
And I thought I am just sick of that.
And so the minister came to see me.
And I said, do you advertise what goes on in your bedroom?
Well, no. And I said, well, I don't know why lesbians have to advertise that they're that persuasion.
And so I said, I'm just not going to support the church until you change your rules.
And so that's...
You've moved on from there now.
And it was more a matter of how public she was being about it.
Yes, yes. I don't care.
The whole Mac teachers over here have always lived together.
But they haven't advertised what...
And a lot of them were just doing it because they needed friendship.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
But to advertise how you feel about your personal, it just calls me.
And I don't mind if you print that.
That's an important stance, I think.
I think that's good.
If you had to pinpoint what you're grateful for in this life,
you've talked so much about your family and things like that.
Are there particular things that you think about how grateful you are to have had in your life?
Yes, I think I'm grateful for the fact that I've had a good education
and that I have been able to use it in many different ways.
And that I've been able to contribute to society.
Yes, and that I've been able to earn enough money to live comfortably.
And to share what you have.
Yes.
Is there anything that feels unfinished about your life at this point?
Are there things that you still have left to do or that you feel like you would like to do better?
Well...
No, I don't really think there's any unfinished business.
Well, I don't know that I had any great broad plans to do anything.
It kind of all just sort of evolved.
That's life.
I don't think I had any grand notions of what I could accomplish or anything.
It was just that when the opportunity came and I could see that I could help a little bit.
I took advantage of that, but there wasn't anything premeditated.
Do you have any advice on thinking about your grandchildren and great grandchildren reading this and wondering if there is anything that you would suggest to them as in terms of an overall way to live your life?
Well, I think the main thing is that you need to be fair and you need to be honest.
And you need to take advantage of opportunities that are presented themselves.
I just think that it's important that you be happy.